Where we left off in the last
video, Napoleon was doing
pretty well.
In 1804, just as a bit of
review, he declared himself
Emperor Napoleon I.
And then, the whole last video
was about the Third Coalition
that formed in 1805.
And we saw that at the end of
1805, after the Battle of
Austerlitz, Napoleon was able to
crush the Third Coalition,
which was mainly made up
of Russia and Austria.
And this is all review.
We saw this in the last video.
And the big by-product of that,
other than the fact that
it just made everyone think gee,
this Napoleon guy, he's
pretty formidable, is that it
ended the Holy Roman Empire.
Which you remember was
neither holy, nor
Roman, nor an empire.
It was really just
a collection of
German speaking states.
But it ended the official
Holy Roman Empire.
And Napoleon felt so good about
himself at this point,
especially after crushing the
Austrian and Russian forces at
Austerlitz, that he had the Arc
de Triomphe, which if you
go to Paris right now,
it's one of the
things you should see.
He had this built.
And now it's to commemorate all
of the soldiers who have
died for France.
But it was originally built
by Napoleon, or it was
commissioned by Napoleon, to
celebrate his victory at
Austerlitz.
So this is the Arc
de Triomphe.
My spelling is always
a little weak.
But it's especially weak
when I'm spelling
something in French.
And that's right there.
So Napoleon was doing
pretty well.
Now, on the other side of the
equation, you could imagine
that the other major powers of
Europe were kind of licking
their wounds.
They weren't sure what was
going on and they were
starting to feel threatened.
And in particular, this guy
started to feel especially
threatened.
This is Frederick-- once again
my spelling is not the
strongest, especially when I'm
doing something in German--
Frederick Wilhelm III.
It actually took me a long time
to realize that Wilhelm
and William are the
same names.
And William is just the
English version of it.
But this is Frederick
Wilhelm III and he
is the King of Prussia.
And he stayed out of the action
during the Third Coalition.
And even now, Prussia is
a major European power.
And he gets threatened by this
rising power of Napoleon, who
was able to break up, or almost
take away Austria's
influence from the Holy
Roman Empire.
And now it kind of becomes this
Confederation of the Rhine.
Let me show you the map.
So this whole area over here.
All of this right over here,
which is now mainly modern day
Germany, that used to be the
Holy Roman Empire, it's
emperor was the King of
Austria, who wasn't
necessarily in it, but it kind
of implies some type of
allegiance.
This is France right here.
Once he was able to trounce
Austria in Austerlitz--
Austria and Russia-- then
this becomes the
Confederation of the Rhine.
Let me highlight this
a little bit better.
So this general area.
Holy Roman Empire no
longer exists.
And it now becomes kind of a
satellite region of France.
France has a huge amount
of control.
So you could imagine that the
King of Prussia starts getting
a little bit threatened.
France is on its borders, it has
shown itself to be able to
defeat other great
powers with ease.
So this guy gets a little
paranoid whether he feels that
France might kind of threaten
Prussia's power.
Or maybe on the other side of
the equation, that he just
didn't like this upstart who was
not related to all of the
other royalty of Europe.
He maybe wanted to put
him in his place.
So Frederick Wilhelm
III declares war.
We're now in 1806.
We have Prussia declares
war on France.
And you're going to see this
pattern multiple times.
And the one thing to kind of
remember, if you just want to
remember kind of major themes.
We're always talking about the
First Coalition, Second
Coalition, Third Coalition,
Fourth
Coalition, all of these.
And it's always some combination
of Britain.
And Britain has kind of already
dominated the ocean.
So when we talk about these
battles on land, we're not
talking about Britain much.
But this whole time, Britain is
in the background trying to
be a pain in France's neck.
And then all the other
coalitions are some
combination of Prussia,
Austria, and Russia.
And some other countries
here and there.
But you see one after another
that they keep challenging
Napoleon up to this point.
And Napoleon keeps trouncing
them, takes more and more land
and territory and
power from them.
And they get even more insecure
and then they want to
form other coalitions.
So this happens again.
And this is the start of
the Fourth Coalition.
In the last video,
it was the third.
This is now the formation
of the fourth.
And essentially, the coalition
forms as soon as someone else
other than Great Britain
joins the fight.
Because Great Britain is kind
of in a continuous war with
Napoleon over this entire
time period.
So we've got this Fourth
Coalition that forms. We've
got Prussia, we've got Great
Britain, and Russia wants to
join the fight again.
So as you can imagine, the end
of the Third Coalition didn't
keep Russia out of the
fight for long.
Let me write it down.
You have Prussia, Russia,
and Great Britain.
There's always some other
actors, but these are the
major ones.
And it was kind of silly
on the part of Prussia.
Because Prussia would've been in
a much better situation if
it had helped the
Third Coalition.
Maybe that would have
changed the outcome.
But now they're kind of taking
on Napoleon, at least
initially on their own.
Because Russia is always kind of
behind Austria or Prussia,
depending which coalition
you're talking about.
So Prussia and Austria
are always the
first line of offense.
In this case, in the Fourth
Coalition, it's Prussia.
And they get trounced
in Jena-Auerstedt.
Let me show you where that is.
So this is actually Napoleon
getting the troops together at
Jena-Auerstedt.
This right here is a charge of
the French troops there.
Let me write this down.
Two cities close by each
other in Germany.
They are roughly around here.
Let's see, this map is a little
difficult to read.
But they're roughly in that
area right there.
Napoleon, once again,
he trounces Prussia.
So Prussia is just
out of the way.
That's in October of 1806.
And then Napoleon essentially
chases the Russians through
most of what's now Poland.
He has this hugely bloody
stalemate at Eylau.
I don't even know
how to say that.
It's right around there.
If I read my maps correctly.
So a stalemate.
This is in 1807.
Stalemate, February 1807
at-- let me get the
spelling right, E-Y-L-A-U.
Super bloody.
They actually win the battle.
But they aren't able to
decisively defeat the Russian
troops, or the Russian army.
And there are estimates that
in that one battle, there's
anywhere from 15,000 to 25,000
casualties on both sides.
Which was huge at that time.
Even now, if you think about
even modern wars, that's a
major amount of casualties
to have in
just one single battle.
But Napoleon persists, and
he's eventually able to
decisively meet the Russians at
Friedland, which is right
about there.
That is in June of 1807.
And then he's able
to decisively
defeat the Fourth Coalition.
So here we we're kind of
at the summer of 1807.
We're talking about June is
when Friedland occurs,
Russians decisively defeated.
The Prussians were already
trounced several months ago.
And then in July of '07, July
of 1807, you have France
signing the Treaties
of Tilsit.
And it's called the Treaties
of Tilsit, instead of the
Treaty of Tilsit, because he
signed separate treaties with
Russia and Prussia.
At this point, Napoleon
had kind of lost
all respect for Prussia.
And he wanted to show it.
So he had a separate treaty with
Prussia and a separate
treaty with Russia.
The one with Russia was a
lot more respectable.
It had all this language about
how Napoleon and Tsar
Alexander I are now friends.
This is Tsar Alexander
I right here.
And as you'll see, this
friendship is very temporary.
As you could imagine, I mean
this is the guy Napoleon
defeated at Austerlitz
not too long ago.
So all this friendship should
probably be written in quotes.
But the treaty with Russia
was very friendly.
And I think Napoleon still
respected Russia's power.
So friendly with Russia, it
declared them allies.
But the other Treaty of Tilsit
with Prussia carved it up.
Carved up Prussia.
And the main thing it did, if we
look at this map here, this
is a map of central Europe.
Or I guess Prussia and Austria
and France at the end of the
Third Coalition.
The main thing it did, it took
the territory west of the
river Elbe from Prussia.
So this is the river
Elbe right here.
The blue is Prussia after
the Third Coalition.
So all of this stuff gets
taken away from Prussia.
And most of it turns into a
French satellite kingdom
called the Kingdom
of Westphalia.
So this is part of the Prussian
Treaty of Tilsit.
So you have the Kingdom
of Westphalia.
And to really emphasize,
it really is a
French satellite state.
And to add insult to injury to
the Prussians, Napoleon puts
his brother Jerome as king.
So it really is a satellite
state of France.
So here at the end of this,
the other powers in Europe
haven't learned that this
Napoleon character with his
grand army, this huge army that
he's been able to raise
and his military tactics, really
is someone formidable
to deal with.
So they keep, Third Coalition,
and then they lose territory.
Then the Fourth Coalition,
then they
lose even more territory.
So what happens at the end of
this Fourth Coalition, and
actually during the Fourth
Coalition, after Napoleon
defeated Prussia, he realized
gee, you know what?
I have, I'm in either direct
control or indirect control of
a significant part of Europe.
And at the same time, he knew
that Britain had complete
domination of the oceans.
And it was this kind of rising
industrial power.
It was the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution.
So Napoleon's ideas, well I
can't defeat Great Britain on
the waters.
Did I say Russia?
No I've been saying-- the whole
point is that Great
Britain is dominant
on the oceans.
And Napoleon realizes
that he can't invade
Great Britain by sea.
He can't do anything in the
water with Great Britain kind
of pestering him.
So what he tries to do is
declare economic warfare on
Great Britain.
And he institutes at
the end of 1806,
the Continental System.
So I'll put this right here.
This is in November of 1806.
So this is right after he
trounces the Prussians at
Jena-Auerstedt.
This is in November of 1806,
where he's feeling really good
about his strength on the
actual continent.
He institutes what he calls
the Continental System.
And this is really just the
notion of economic warfare
with Great Britain.
That hey, if you are either a
part of the French Empire,
controlled by the French Empire,
or aligned with the
French Empire, you embargo
Great Britain.
This little island, it controls
the waters, but it is
dependant on trade.
So Napoleon's idea through this
Continental System is to
embargo the United Kingdom of
Great Britain, whatever we
want to call it.
Embargo Great Britain.
And one thing he got out of
the Russians, this was
actually a huge concession,
because Russia was a major
power at the time.
He got them, through the Treaty
of Tilsit, to also join
the Continental System.
Let me write that in a color
that'll actually show up.
And in return, he also got some
land, some islands, the
Ionian Islands off the western
coast of Greece.
And some of the land off the
Dalmatian coast. Let me show
you right there.
So this area over here.
And Russia in return, and it's
pretty good because Russia
essentially lost the war, but in
return they were allowed to
do whatever they want with
the Ottoman Empire.
And we'll talk more about the
Ottoman Empire in future
videos, but if you want to have
a general view of what
the Ottoman Empire is, I guess
the last remnant of it is what
is today modern Turkey.
But obviously it was an
empire at that time.
But Russia and the Ottoman
Empire were kind of that at
odds with each other.
So it was great for Russia to
say hey, I'm going to be able
to do whatever I want with
the Ottoman Empire.
Because before this, Napoleon
was nominally
aligned with the Ottomans.
So this was actually a big
concession for Russia.
So at the end of this, we have
a situation once again, I
guess the other powers
don't realize it.
Over and over, Third Coalition,
Napoleon, he really
takes care of the Russians
and the Austrians.
Destroys the Holy Roman
Empire, makes it the
Confederation of the Rhine
under Napoleon's control.
Prussia wants to put
down Napoleon.
Declares war again,
Fourth Coalition.
The only by-product of that is
now they lose this land.
Napoleon becomes
even stronger.
Puts his brother as king in
the kingdom of Westphalia.
And now he has Russia
as an ally to help
his embargo on England.
So really, after the end of the
Fourth Coalition, a lot of
historians view this as kind
of the height of Napoleon's
power in Europe.